All right.
Allah
I should
[Silence]
adore.
I shall
[Silence]
Oh,
I
[Silence]
Allah
in the Lord. Oh,
awesome.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Allah. foreign.
foreign.
[Silence]
When we look back
at how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
chains events together
and seemingly random occurrences
turn into
a momentous plan.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala began the
journey of Ysef Alisam
with a whisper from a shan
that the
brothers the elder brothers of Ysef
Alisam felt a tinge of jealousy towards
their two younger brothers Ysef and his
younger brother Benjamin Benamian.
And so the story of Yuis
unfolded
when they decided to act on that
jealousy.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
took those efforts that a shan so
diligently put forth and he turned them
into the momentum needed to forge the
likes of Yuis
and al
and the tribes of the 12 tribes of Benny
Israel that followed.
We see that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has certain plans
in place, certain things that are to
take place.
And when we arrive at those plans and
everything is uncovered, it seems like
it could have been no other way. But
when we look back
at the start of those plans, the match
that was first struck to light that
fire,
we see that it is often times connected
to rather innocuous
occurrences that at the time strike
the people involved as random,
as coincidence.
as luck.
But there is no luck.
Coincidence is a fancy word that human
beings use
to describe what they don't understand.
With Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, there is
no coincidence.
It is a plan written 50,000
years before the creation of the heavens
and the earth.
And not one thing on this earth occurs.
Not one mosquito bats its wings.
Not one thought goes through a person's
mind.
Not one movement of the eyes or beating
of a heart. No matter how obscure
anywhere on this earth in its entire
history except that it was part of that
greater plan.
Allah subhanahu waala says
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
created everything on this earth
for a purpose
for a reason. There is no extra there is
no level in the actions and the creation
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We see that years and years and years
ago before the conquest of Mecca
that Mecca is in a very very obscure and
cut off place. It's in the smack dab in
the middle of a of one of the harshest
deserts on Earth.
It's a very difficult place to survive.
And the survival of Mecca hinges and
relies heavily on diplomacy
with other lands in order that they may
import all of their sustenance to this
dot in the middle of nowhere.
And so one of the greatest alliances
that Bur maintained
even before the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam was a messenger
was their allegiance and alliance with
the people of Yan,
the people of Benihan.
This is a land that is to the east of
Mecca
or it's actually more towards the
northeast of Mecca and it is directly
east of Medina and it's a place that is
was at the time very rich
it in its grains and its production of
grains wheat and barley and all of these
things that are necessities things that
keep really well in the desert.
And so
more than half
of Mecca's sustenance
comes from that direction. It was one of
the most precious alliances
for the people of Mecca.
And fortunately enough, the people of
Yemen were very devout people.
They were very religious.
They would come for Hajj and Omrah
constantly. And so there was kind of a
mutual respect
between the people of Yana and
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam tried
and tried with the people of Yama.
However, they were feeding into the
propaganda
of Qur
and they would refuse to listen to the
point that the people of Benihanifa
became some of the most staunch
opponents of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
It got to a point that they would go out
of their way to send assassins
to try to murder the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
And just before hijah, if you were to
look around at that time, it would seem
the Muslims and Islam was failing.
They had no major allegiance.
And they had just come out of being cut
off when
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam and
his companions and Banu Abdalib were
pressed by the people of Quraysh into
the valley of and they were starved
there. Banu Hanifh refused to give them
a single grain for two consecutive
years.
The famine was so terrible that it was
said that at night for miles you could
hear the wailing and als
in the valley of Ebalib
as they were
ailing and wailing and crying from
hunger.
And Benohhanifha refused to give them
even one grain. And they were feeling
pretty good about themselves with this.
They were able to maintain and leverage
their political alliances
to starve the prophet sallall.aii
and his companions.
One of the most staunch
antagonists
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
was a man
named Thumama.
Thum
and Thumma he wasn't just a regular
Joemo in
Benihanifa and amongst the people of
Yemen. He was say Benihanifa.
He was considered to be one of their
highest
tribesmen.
And he commanded thousands of men
that were at his becking call.
And he also controlled the grain trade
from Yamama.
Now he hated the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam so much
that he decided to go out and try to
find him and kill him on his own. Murder
him himself.
This is a tribesman. This is a a leader.
He doesn't have to lift a finger. the
son has barely had at his skin since his
birth.
But he hated him so much he wanted to do
it himself.
And so in the sixth year after Hijra,
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
sent a battalion out in those directions
because they were having an ongoing
problem with Benibi Baka.
And as his troops were returning,
they came across a man who was out in
the desert by himself
or he had a few men with him. It wasn't
with a caravan
and they took him. They didn't know who
this man was.
And this is hostile territory here. And
so they took him back to Medina. They
had no idea who this man was.
And he's telling them that he is
Thumama. And they're saying, "Yeah,
right. Okay. Thouama." They don't know
who this man is.
And so when the companions arrived back
in Medina, who do they have with them
but
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam saw
him and said,
"Do you guys have any idea who this guy
is?"
They said, "Some guy we found him out in
the desert." He said,
It was a kind of happy accident, right?
A coincidence.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
deliberated for a moment
and then told them to tie him to one of
the pillars in the masid. And so they
did.
He came to Thumana
and he said,
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam asked
what's the word?
He said
[Silence]
He said, "If you kill me," this is WHAT
HE EXPECTS. WHY does he expect that he's
going TO BE KILLED? WHY DOES HE expect
that he's going to be killed? Because
that's what he would have done.
BECAUSE THAT'S what he was trying to do.
He set out for Omrah. He was going for
Omrah. But just to kind of dot his eyes
and cross his tees, he wanted to see if
he could assassinate the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam on his way to
Omrah.
What kind of Omrah is this?
And so
this is what he would have done. This is
what how he sees the world. And we see
the world as we do.
that a person sees the world as he
behaves.
A thief thinks everyone else is a thief
because that's how he sees the world. A
killer thinks everyone else is out to
get him because that's how he sees the
world. A liar thinks everyone else is
lying because that's how he sees the
world. A coward cannot fathom courage.
A coward only understands fear because
that's how he sees the world. Fumana
sees the world through the lens of
blood.
And so he expected the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam to kill him. And
why not? They have a rivalry going back
for almost 20 years.
And now here he is in the middle of
Medina tied to a random post.
And so he asked him, "What's the word?"
He said, "If you kill me, you are going
to kill a man who has very valuable and
precious blood to his people.
And if you release me, you will release
a very thankful person. And if you want
money, just name your price.
I could get you any amount of money that
you want.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam left him there
and he remained tied to that pillar in
the masid
for the duration of the next day and
night. The next day around the same
time, the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam came to ask him again
and he said the same thing he said the
day before
he said if you kill me you are going to
kill a man with very precious and
valuable blood to his people. Don't
think that that's the end of it. My
people will seek retribution.
And if you release me, you will release
someone who will be thankful to you. And
if you want money, just name your price.
And so he left him again for a second
day. On the third day, he came again and
asked him,
"Let's see if your tune has changed."
And said the exact same thing, the same
thing he's been pariting the entire
time. If you kill me, then that's not
the end of it. My people will seek
retribution.
I'm a trib's leader.
And if you release me, you will release
someone that will repay you and be
grateful. And if you want money, then
ask me and I will give you whatever
money you want to secure my release.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said,
"Let him go."
And so Thumana anxious to get off that
pillar for the past three days. He's
been tied to this pillar in the masid.
He went out of the masid.
And really he came right back in only a
few minutes later
and he said,
I testify
that none is rightfully worshiped but
Allah and that you oh Muhammad are the
messenger of Allah.
He said there was no face on this earth
more
more hated to me than your face. And
today I find your face to be the most
loved of faces on this earth to me.
And there is never a land more hated to
me than this land. And this city of
yours here.
And today this city is the most beloved
of cities to me.
And there was no religion that I hated
more fervently than your religion.
But today I do testify that it is the
most beloved of religions to me.
Thma had actually gone out of the masid,
bathed, and then returned. How did he
know to bathe? Well, he's been in the
masid for 3 days listening TO THE QURAN.
WHAT DID HE HEAR and see while he was in
the masid for those three days? I tell
you this is how the prophet Sam
treated his enemies. Could you imagine
how he used to treat his friends?
If we could choose, IF I COULD CHOOSE to
go back to any time, I would choose to
go back and be tied to that pillar in
the masid today. That is a privilege
that Thumama received.
What did he see in the masid? HE SAW MEN
there that barely had enough clothing to
cover themselves,
yet they're sharing.
Men who have barely enough food to eat,
but they're splitting it up. Men who
stand for salah five times a day
memorize and listen to the most pure and
wise words that have ever graced his
ears. He's watching and learning because
he was brainwashed by and their
propaganda.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
could have really used
back in the early days in Mecca but it
wasn't time yet. It was all part of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's plan.
HE SAID, "I WAS GOING on my way to Mecca
to make Omrah.
What do you think I should do?" The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said, "You
should continue on your path to Omrah."
And is the first Muslim of this to
make
after the hijra of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. That's the first.
And when he arrived in Medi in Mecca, he
made his Omra and of course all of the
big-bellied antagonists of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
came with their chagrins and their
chroing.
Oh, you know here is sayifa
thinking that their alliance is still
untouched and he stood in Mecca there at
the and he said
Muslim
I am now Muslim
and the the tribe leaders of Quraysh
were takenback by this. He said,
"Did you disgrace your forefathers and
change your religion?"
He said, "I tell you what,
not one grain
is going to come to you from Yan
unless
Muhammad Sall.ai was allows it. I swear
not one grain is going to come to you.
Now the shoe is on the other foot
because as the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam and his companions and anyone
affiliated with them were starving in
Sheb.
No one listened to their whales.
They even they even took the treaty that
they wrote and their agreement to starve
the messenger of Allah and his
companions and they hang they hung it up
in the Kaa itself.
This is how wicked and evil these people
are.
They became so hungry they sent so many
delegates to Thulana to try to get him
to just please sell us some grain. And
he said no not until Muhammad says I
can.
And they sent a message to the prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam
begging him please talk to for us so
that we can eat. We're starving out
here. And the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam yet again another position of
power over his enemies. And the grace is
remarkable.
And he sent word to Thumana. Sell him as
you used to. They're at war. He
interceded on behalf of his enemies
in order to feed them.
AND SO WE SEE THAT THUMAMA'S story
doesn't end there because Benu Hanifh
this tribe and Yana
someone that I think every one of us
knows came out of there.
Ma was from Benihanifa.
He heard of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. He accepted Islam from
Thumama. He went to visit him in the
ninth year after hij and he decided
being a prophet is really good for
business. I could be a prophet too. And
he went back to al and he decided he was
a messenger as well. One of the greatest
battles in the history of Islam right
after the death of the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
occurred and it came from the direction
of and once again
was critical in the Muslim being
victorious and rising from the ashes of
that conflict.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
forch.
[Silence]
Allham.
Allah.
[Silence]
for
Allah. for
Allah.
Allah
be
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah
sh
[Silence]
Allah.
Straighten your rope. rows. Please
ensure that your rows are as straight
and coherent as possible by aligning
your shoulders and feet and ankles with
the shoulders and feet and ankles of
your two neighbors on either side of
you.
The straightening of our rows will
directly result and affect the harmony
of our hearts and the reward of our
prayer. Please double check your phones.
Ensure that they are silent.
I saw
beyond the magn Imagine looking.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Fore
[Silence]
speech.
Allah
hol.
[Silence]
Allah
alone. Oh,
alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
amen.
for
[Silence]
Allah. Oh,
I
say me Allah
Allah
Allahbel
exel
Allah
exel Hello.
[Silence]
All
that's Stuffable stuff.
[Silence]
Brothers and sisters, asalam alalaykum.
Couple of quick reminders. First one is
we have the potluck tonight between
Mahab and Isisha. So bring your favorite
food dish and share with the community
inshallah. So it's again it's off
between Mranisha tonight at the masjid.
Number two we have monthly community
the the Quran competition is tomorrow.
Please enroll and schedule online.
Also we have the Sunday program
starting this Sunday. Inshallah the
Sunday will be at 10:30 to 1:30 every
Sunday from on now from tomorrow on or
from this Sunday on. So inshallah you
can you have a chance to benefit from
this school and educate your children
especially those who are in public or
private schools outside that will be a
tremendous benefit for them to connect
with our with our masid inshallah. Also
please donate generously on the way out.
[Arabic recitation]